my face is losing feeling oh wow
[Applause]
what did you guys eat uh growing up for
me my dad he actually uh likes Thai
Chili so every time before a meal he
would usually um eat a little Chili
Pepper thing I grew up eating like that
as well but when you inherited that I
think I inherited yeah probably should
go somewhere up here then uh
one step but you know are you sure you
don't want to do too I mean just two all
right well while we're moving I should I
should be down there because I have had
a jalapeno and that's probably the most
spicy thing I've had so go away
all the way down here was pretty spicy
though yeah I know yeah I think raw
peppers yeah
I mean you might not be at least one
point for that I can do like Tabasco
Sriracha like I have that all the time
that's probably pretty low on the rank I
assume
um I I guess I'm you know the the
classic stereotype white person who
likes I I like buffalo sauce and that's
all I got I will say growing up my Dad
loved spicy so in in my dinners like he
would always put peppers of all all
kinds and I would literally break out in
rashes because of how spicy it was so I
have been training since I was itty
bitty so I feel like I could go a few up
oh yeah yeah he caught me right here
right here okay one similar to you I
actually grew up my dad was like
obsessed with spice he would have
Tabasco but Tabasco on everything and
that's like where my love of spice
started and then I started eating like
hot Cheetos and stuff and I was like
okay with this I'm with this you know
got heartburn a few times so it's okay
actually two years ago I tried uh
Carolina Reaper and I loved it I'ma bump
you up just real quick yeah yeah you
love Reaper I feel like I'm more middle
if we're going by family my mom and my
dad they can't handle anything they
think like you know paprika might be too
spicy I'm different though I feel like
I've acquired a taste for it what do we
think about moving Allen up oh it's up
to you guys I think I'm okay over here I
think so I think you should let's also
going to be one more oh you think
they're over here
yeah yeah
um my background's similar to Allen's
where I grew up with like eating Thai
chilies and bird's eye chilies and a lot
of Southeast Asian Cuisine it's like the
hottest thing that you think you've ever
eaten ghost pepper okay yeah
I feel like I had one of the spiciest
peppers in India it was dried and I
lived you know
did you live well
so I think I could maybe go up a little
bit too sorry I don't know you guys told
me to stop okay we're going here so I
did try some really spicy sauces I don't
know how much the Scoville system is
worth like the hottest one was two
million and I thought it was bearable I
definitely felt the spice I definitely
needed something afterwards but I like
you yeah yeah let's let's switch that
two million one yeah that two million
one is already that's too impressive man
[Applause]
[Music]
so the first sauce is Tabasco
how do you feel about it I like the way
it's flowing okay ready yeah
yeah cheers
like a Lunchable you're right I'm an
adult
lunchable that was not spicy
it's Okay We're Not Gonna judge you man
I'm feeling good that's got me feeling
honestly pretty confident
what do you guys find like the worst
heat like like lip heat mouth heat or
throat you think it's the worst when
it's on the lips yeah
wait when you feel it right here that's
that's what I'm probably going to be
doing I find like tongue heat if it hits
like the back of my tongue the worst
that's game over right there does anyone
have like weird reactions when you have
spicy like my mom hiccups I do
you'll know I'm reaching like the point
before the end if I start to hiccup
probably I hope we hear that round two
Pirates Lantern it doesn't smell too
small they got the biggest one Curry yes
I saw you avoid that one cheers
such a friendly crew I love it
I like this one a lot this is good I
actually need to buy this one
is anyone feeling anything yet
physically
lovely
so this next round is called Thor's
hammer
oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
do you guys think that like certain
cultures or certain backgrounds maybe
some like specific races ethnicities
have a stronger tolerance for spice over
others Hispanic or Mexican culture we
really grow up with a lot of spice and
my dad he just took a bite out of a
habanero and then just ate his food at
no sweat no nothing but he's been eating
that since he was little so you know
white people are on like the bottom and
the end of the curve because like
they're either can't tolerate anything
or like you find those like really
crazed-eyed people who are like on
social media who just like double fish
like three different peppers yeah I feel
like it has more to do with your
exposure to different Cuisines ethnic
um dishes tend to have a little bit more
flavor but I don't believe it's fully
based on like your ethnic genetics
um
wake up now
this is the bomb Oh my God
it looks like toxic sludge yo what are
you doing again again he does this
go team cheers
I don't think that was as bad as the
last one I think it might come in a
second I think it's a slow heat yeah
you're right there we go that's like
that's pain to me this right here yeah a
lot guys with me let's keep you in the
zone you've got this I mean it's just
like dranoline like I'm good but maybe a
turtleneck wasn't the Wi-Fi
look fashionable while you just burn on
the inside channeling that inner Steve
Jobs
no one else crying I was like are you
guys okay staring up a little
um
[Laughter]
what do you think is the spiciest
Cuisine I had wings from a South African
Place one time and it was just just a
little bit of the wing like like less
sauce than what we're having now and
some guy who thought he was like you
know really really hot stuff ate a whole
wing with it he was in the bathroom for
like two hours man he couldn't get out
this is kind of gross especially since
we're eating but have any of you guys
ever vomited from spicy sauce no
man
oh that was bad
hey good humans
humans better help for sponsoring this
portion of today's video better help is
the world's largest therapy service and
it's 100 online
to get started all you need to do is
answer a few questions about your needs
and preferences in therapy that way
better help can match you with the right
therapist from their Network then you
can talk to your therapist however you
feel comfortable whether it's via text
chat phone or video call you can message
your therapist at any time and schedule
live sessions when it's convenient for
you if your therapist isn't the right
fit for any reason you can switch to a
new therapist at no additional charge
with better help you get the same
professionalism and quality you expect
from in-office therapy but with a
therapist who is custom picked for you
more scheduling flexibility and a more
affordable price check out the link in
the description below get 10 off your
first month at betterhelp.com Jubilee
media that's better help.com Jubilee
media thanks again better help for
sponsoring this episode now let's get
back to the video in this next and final
sauce is called Mad Dog 357. oh it has a
6 million Scoville
prayer first things moving oh it does
not taste I don't like that flavor at
all
oh God it's like my college course right
now oh mine cheap vodka oh no oh my gosh
oh wow
this tastes like something some things
it's like something and I can't put my
finger on it like a straight like the
devil's pepper
I know what you mean that's what you're
talking about yeah
I'm going numb
oh my God
that just doesn't taste great it does it
it doesn't feel good I don't know who
would want that there's the hiccups I
told you
oh crap
out yeah one word how would you describe
your current state
not okay there's the tears I think that
was like two words five
um hot
wow uh yeah oh I'm sorry I'm trying it
this way
even more
my body's getting numb
my face is losing here I'm losing
feeling
this game tingly
on my lips right now
it's getting worse
you know it's bad when we're just
breathing yeah
goodness I might have to tap out I think
so too I thought I was really strong but
my face
you made it I actually can't feel my
body bad dog I can't my face is losing
feeling I'm so proud of you oh yeah no
I'm right behind you girl
SOS I can barely talk okay
it worked good luck guys am I making a
crazy face right now
looking man it's just gonna get worse
isn't it oh God we think the bread might
have been too easy for you guys so now
we're just gonna give you the sauce on a
spoon
right
all right
[Applause]
honestly it looks like you're handling
it the best you might have to just oh
yeah
it's like a piece of cake
I might think I'm I think I'm closer
down here
it's cold all right
I feel like we need it yeah
uh wait wait so we're going straight on
the tongue we'll flip it or
that seems like that
all right here we go
on the lips beautiful
you good bro I didn't take it in yep
oh yeah
I'm ironing it I'm buying that cup so
can you tell me about your job how you
started yeah
um it wasn't hot sauce
he went to the school for computer
science and I thought it would be
interesting computer science yeah for me
I wanted to put it around here
I start off as a heart major one
including arts art was food culinary
arts then we took a bow class we had a
presentation
honestly I'm filming up there yeah
you're good yeah yeah I won't talk
anymore you guys go you might help man
you're good half of this I'm Gonna Be
Alive yeah be real alive there's no way
I'm tapping out no you can't man you
can't gone too far Don't Stop Believing
your dreams
is there alcohol in this or passion I'm
a filmmaker photographer I did
voiceovers actor you guys need me let me
know I love you Mom Dad do you do voices
yeah you do well let's hear it all right
okay all right why
why oh my God
why so serious
thank you all right that's time you guys
all made it yeah you guys can take a sip
of milk if you want all right a little
sit remember but you guys did amazing
thank you no I'm good
is this the order of who got out I think
I was out yeah you were right then you
four yeah yeah Alan your reaction was
very beautiful I think I think you got
to be under her yeah are we under here I
think so yeah I think so it was Oscar
worthy though between you and me I don't
know I think you might have been you
might have been what do you guys think I
don't know the both of you were very
unfazed yeah I don't know that's like a
tie to me I think it's a good time you
want to do chug the bottles no I'm good
right here
is anyone surprised at their results
really yeah I
confident I'm not gonna lie so the fact
that I went out first I mean I could not
feel my face really and so I had to get
out but you guys are impressive I Gotta
Give big props to Bryce this man I don't
know how you know what I feel like my
body said no but my mind said yes you
were determined that got me through so
from jalapeno to six million yeah dude
crazy now you can say yeah
has this challenge ruins hot sauce for
anyone else absolutely not hey Paulo
here do you feel the spice well if you
do make sure to like this video And
subscribe to our Channel I want that
mustard one again I want a big bottle of
that I want to take that home I don't
want the last one ever no no no I didn't
like the taste of it yeah
pretty good for how hot it was